so okay trump does his rally in florida
it's riddled with lies it's pathetic
it's authoritarian it's hypocritical
fine in the sense that it's what we've
come to expect and what we've come to
know
but understand that without trump
supporters
who are willing to stand around for 12
hours waiting for the rally
uh and are willing to it's not even take
in and accept
it's there's not even the possibility
that they would question any of the
things that donald trump says during
these rallies without those people there
really is no rally
it's just trump speaking to an empty
room so let's look
at some trump supporter interviews from
the rally in sarasota florida and this
is going to set us up for our
conversation that i'll be having after
the
break about why i believe that if donald
trump does run in 2024
um it's not good at all for the biden
harris ticket i think biden harris are
in real trouble if trump runs
we're gonna get to that okay but first
trump supporters
here's one being interviewed by real
america's voice and check out it's
we've talked about delusional before
this is not just delusional
this is a sort of defiant and proud
delusion that is different than a lot of
what we've seen
prior to the trumpian era take a look at
this supporter a trump supporter
why are you continuing to support the
president so aggressively and
passionately
still right now in 2021 and this is a
key why is this a key question
i mean you know real america's voice
these people are this is all terrible
but
why is this a key question because if we
want to figure out what 22 and 24 will
likely look like this is the perfect
question why are you still supporting
this guy so aggressively he lost
everything for you
he lost 18 in 18 he lost the house for
you in 20 he lost the white house and
the senate well but they don't even
believe that
that's the key because he really won the
election he loves our country
he loves our veterans um he wants there
it is
there it is uncritically accepting
there's not even a chance she wouldn't
accept it trump's the trumps the
president right now that's why i support
him
she says safe borders and he's our
president
and i just love him because he loves
america so much he stands for everything
america is
and understand that this no no
particular offense to this woman this is
just trump
trump as a privileged new york city born
and raised guy
has spent his life trying to stay away
from uh women like this woman i'm not
pre-picking on her in particular i mean
it applies to everybody
right the workers actually doing the
work building trump's real estate
projects
the people donating to trump's campaign
all of these people
are useful and valuable to trump only as
far as
they can they can assist him in whatever
his immediate goals are
he wants nothing to do with these people
in reality he's not racist like they say
he is
and um i love him that's why god too
i mean and great people like you guys to
bring us together and tell us the real
truth
i wish more people were watching and
hearing the real truth yeah
so there's just not you know the
language that's being used that is cult
language
that is cult language and you know i we
we've um
if you want more sort of texture
to understand that language and these
ideologies
check out the interview i did with
stephen hassan about
cultishness read the road to jonestown
about jim jones people's temple
i'm now reading going clear by lawrence
wright about scientology
it's trumpism it's trumpism that's what
it is when you when you read it and and
you then see these people that's what it
is
let's go to another one of these this
one now is from newsmax
uh these are more interviews with trump
supporters at the rally
love trump i think he's the best thing
that happened to our country
and now it's being destroyed what makes
you love trump so much
free enterprise system you know it's all
about free enterprise system and the
second amendment
and we're all pro cops of course and
understand
if you actually say to these folks
so what did trump do on second amendment
and then what did biden do
that is so restricting your ability to
own guns i guarantee you
they will not actually be able to name
anything trump actually did
on firearms he actually did very little
it was mostly rhetoric
and with biden they also will be unable
to name anything now biden has tried to
do a couple of things they're all
totally milk toast
establishing a commission to study x and
uh buckling down a little bit
on ghost gun sales which is not you know
it's a problem but it's not going to
restrict in all likelihood that guy's
ability to get guns
it's just made up it's there's nothing
there still a lot of great patriots in
this country and we're not going to let
the left take it from us
if this becomes socialism where in the
world
where will we go and again so it's that
this is the effectiveness of propaganda
what's socialism what are you talking
about give us an exam i mean
listen when i when jesse lee peterson
interviewed me this promise sort of
prominent
cartoonishly uh prominent black
conservative
and he said socialism socialism i said
what's an example of socialism under
obama he said
what about those obama phones that's
what he was able to come up with there's
no substance here
i want to keep socialism away from the
united states oh i'm
here because the country is
not going in the right direction how so
i will let you know that i was
a registered democrat since 1976. can
you tell me a little bit about your
message fight terrorism support israel
yeah it's really very simple uh we have
a threat
from people screaming death to america
death to israel
same group same insanity
these people are so gross like their
their quote support of israel
is just it's it's disgustingly misplaced
and if we don't fight back we show our
weakness
i'm here to show that people still love
him even when he's
so far in retirement but we'll see what
happens the journey isn't over it's just
beginning
uh we have the opportunity to uh to make
america great again we hit a bump in the
road we got
knocked out australian guy apparently
loves trump over by the election by
covet but we're gonna come back we'll
come back stronger than ever why is
trump having a rally
when there's three and a half more years
until he's he can run
and i said it's about hope it's awesome
and though the vibe here is so great and
everybody's so positive and everybody's
so excited there is a hope for america
there's a hope for our future
so that is uh that that is that and so
after the break i'm going to explain to
you why i believe
if trump runs in 24 joe and kamala are
in trouble we'll have more clips from
this event
um on our instagram which you can find
at david pakman show follow me on
instagram at david.pacman see pictures
from
my recent uh escapades which i'll talk
about more
on today's bonus show if you ever feel
like you just don't have enough time to
read all the books you want to read
you have to check out one of my favorite
apps called blinkist blinkist takes
thousands of popular nonfiction books
and distills
each one down into an e-book or
audiobook
that you can get through in just 15
minutes where you're getting all the key
takeaways from the book
just imagine how you'll be able to
expand your horizons and knowledge
by being able to soak up all of the
important insights from
10 different books in an afternoon
obviously it's perfect for exposing
yourself to a new book
you otherwise wouldn't have time for or
you can use it to revisit a book you've
already read
or use it to preview a book before you
buy the full version and read it
i recently read a brief history of time
of course by the great
stephen hawking this is a book that i
have been aware of for so long
and other things got in the way and it
was fantastic
to check it out on blinkist blinkist has
books on politics philosophy science
they have 27 different non-fiction
categories and a subscription is only
about eight bucks a month
and you get the entire library but
you can try it totally free and get 25
off a subscription
when you go to blinkist.com pacman
i've put the link right underneath this
video